♪
>> Dana: FOX NEWS ALERT.
ATTORNEY GENERAL WILLIAM
BARR TELLING CONGRESS IT
WILL BE -- HE WILL SEND THEM
THE 400 PAGE MUELLER REPORT
BY MID APRIL, IF NOT SOONER.
BARR SAYING THAT PORTIONS OF
THE SPECIAL COUNSEL'S
FINDINGS THEY ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO BE WE AMERICANS WITH
DISABILITIES ACTED DIEWGD
MATERIAL SUBJECT TO CRIMINAL
PROCEDURES AND INTELLIGENCE
COMMUNITY SOURCES AND
METHODS.
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL ADDING
THAT THE WHITE HOUSE WILL
NOT BE REVIEWING THE REPORT
BEFORE IT'S SENT TO CAPITOL
HILL.
THIS IS PART IS GETTING A
LOT OF ATTENTION.
BARR SAYING SOME
MISCHARACTERIZING HIS FOUR
PAGE SUMMARY.
HE SAYS THE SUMMARY WAS ONLY
ABOUT PRINCIPLE CONCLUSIONS
AND NOTHING MORE.
BARR ALSO SAID HE IS WILLING
TO TESTIFY BEFORE CONGRESS
AFTER THE REPORT IS MADE
PUBLIC AND HE GAVE THEM A
COUPLE OF DATES FOR THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP REACTING TO
THE NEWS JUST MOMENTS AGO.
>> WE'LL HAVE GREAT
CONFIDENCE IN THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
AND IF THAT'S WHAT HE WOULD
LIKE TO DO, I HAVE NOTHING
TO HIDE.
THIS WAS A HOAX.
THIS WAS A WITCH-HUNT.
I HAVE ABSOLUTELY NOTHING TO
HIDE.
AND I THINK A LOT OF THINGS
ARE COMING OUT WITH RESPECT
TO THE OTHER SIDE.
BUT, I HAVE A LOT OF
CONFIDENCE IN THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
>> Dana: ALL RIGHT YOU,, JESSE,
THIS IS GETTING A LOT OF
ATTENTION THIS WEEK WE HAVE
BEEN REPORTING THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT SAYS IT
WILL BE WEEKS, NOT MONTHS,
THAT PEOPLE WILL GET TO SEE
THIS FULL REPORT.
ENOUGH TO WE KNOW IT'S
REALLY JUST A COUPLE OF
WEEKS.
IT'S NOT LIKE 8 WEEKS.
THEN THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
SAYS AND I'M WILLING TO COME
UP AND EXPLAIN IT ALL TO
YOU.
I WILL TESTIFY IN FRONT OF
CONGRESS AND STILL CHAIRMAN
NADLER HE IS MAD.
>> Jesse: RIGHT.
BARR IS A TOTAL PRO.
HE HAS HIS EYES ON THE ROAD.
HE HAS HIS HANDS ON THE
WHEEL.
AND DEMOCRATS, THE KIDS IN
THE BACK ARE WE THERE YET?
ARE WE THERE YET?
HE IS NOT EVEN LISTENING.
HE IS GOING TO GET TO THE
DESTINATION.
>> Dana: DON'T MAKE ME PULL
THIS CAR OVER.
>> Jesse: DON'T MAKE ME PULL
THIS CAR OVER, KIDS.
HE IS DOING IT BY THE BOOK.
HE HAS IMPECCABLE
CREDENTIALS.
DEMOCRATS ARE SETTING
THEMSELVES UP FOR MORE
DISAPPOINTMENT THEY SEE
THERE IS NO COLLUSION.
BARR CRIMINAL CONSPIRACY TO
COVER UP RUSSIAN COLLUSION
WITH ROD ROSENSTEIN AND OUT
REST OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE.
I JUST DON'T THINK THAT'S
TRUE.
CAN WE MAKE A TRIP DOWN WHAT
ABOUTISM LANE?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dana: JESSE, TAKE THE
WHEEL.
>> Jesse: CONSPIRACY AND
COVERUP.
HOW ABOUT WHEN HILLARY
BLEECHESD 30,000 EMAILS OR
DESTROYED ALL OF THE
BLACKBERRIES WITH A HAMMER
OR WHEN HER HUSBAND MET WITH
THE WOMAN INVESTIGATING HER
ON A TARMAC AND EVERYBODY
PLED THE FIFTH?
AND EVERYBODY GOT IMMUNITY
DEALS, PERMISSION TO GO A
LITTLE FARTHER DOWN THAT?
HOW ABOUT WHEN THE IRS
DESTROYED TONS OF SERVERS OR
WHEN THE A.G. AT THE TIME
HOLDER WAS HELD IN CONTEMPT
FOR NOT DISCLOSING ALL THE
INFORMATION ABOUT FAST AND
FURIOUS?
WHERE ALL THE CONTRACTORS OF
BENGALS WERE MADE TO
BENGHAS WERE MADE TO
BENGHAZIWERE MADE TO
BENGHAZI WRE MADE TO
BENGHAZI WER MADE TO
BENGHAZI WEREMADE TO
BENGHAZI WERE MDE TO
BENGHAZI WERE MAD TO
BENGHAZI WERE MADETO
BENGHAZI WERE MADE TO SIGN
NDAs.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE MORE OF A
COVERUP THAN THE COVERUP
GOING ON RIGHT NOW.
I WOULD REMIND THE DEMOCRATS
WHAT THEY SAID THEN WHICH
WAS ABSOLUTELY NOTHING.
>> Dana: ALL RIGHT, JUAN.
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU A
CHANCE TO REVERSE FROM THAT
LANE IF YOU WOULD LIKE.
TO SAY NO, WE'RE GOING TO
STOP THE MET FOR RIGHT
THERE.
DO YOU THINK THIS GETS THE
DEMOCRATS A LITTLE BIT
CLOSER TO WHAT THEY NEED?
WHICH IS THEY SAY THEY WANT
TO SEE IT.
THEY ARE OBVIOUSLY CONCERNED
THERE WILL BE REDACTIONS
WITH REGARDS TO MATERIAL
SUBJECT TO THE GRAND JURY OR
ANYTHING THAT WOULD HURT A
THIRD PARTY THAT WAS
PERIPHERAL AND ALSO ANYTHING
THAT'S INTELLIGENCE-RELATED?
BUT THIS GETS THEM CLOSER TO
WHERE THEY HAVE WANTED TO
BE.
>> WELL, JERRY NADLER, THE
CHAIRMAN, HAD A CONVERSATION
WITH BILL BARR EARLIER THIS
WEEK.
AND HE SAID HE WASN'T
SATISFIED IN THAT
CONVERSATION BECAUSE BARR
INDICATED TO HIM THAT THERE
WOULD BE REDACTIONS IN
WHATEVER IS RELEASED.
HE SAID AT THAT TIME HE
THOUGHT IT WOULD BE, AGAIN,
MID APRIL, WHICH IS WHAT HE
CONFIRMED IN THIS LETTER
TODAY.
WHAT'S THE NEWS OUT OF THE
LETTER FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE
LOOKING AT IT AS TRUMP
CRITICS, IS THAT HE SAID
THAT PEOPLE ARE OVERVALUING
THE EARLIER MISSIVE WHICH
SIMPLY SAID HERE IS THE
BOTTOM LINE IN TERMS OF
CONSPIRACY AND OBSTRUCTION.
HE SAYS IT WAS NOT INTENDED
TO BE AN EXHAUSTIVE REPORT
ON WHAT MUELLER HAD FOUND.
>> Dana: RIGHT.
HE SAYS IN THIS LETTER HE
SAYS AS MY LETTER MADE
CLEAR, MY INNOVATION TO
CONGRESS AND THE PUBLIC
PROVIDED, PENDING RELEASE OF
THE REPORT, A SUMMARY OF ITS
PRINCIPLE CONCLUSION AND
THAT IS ITS BOTTOM LINE.
OF COURSE, WHICH WE KNOW IS
NO COLLUSION.
AND THEN ON THE OBSTRUCTION
PIECE.
>> Juan: THE THING ABOUT
THAT IS IT HAS PROVIDED THE
OPPORTUNITY TO JUMP UP AND
DOWN AND TAKE THE WHEEL FOR
THE LAST WEEK.
I THINK THERE ARE A LOT OF
PEOPLE WHO THINK YOU KNOW
WHAT?
WILLIAM BARR HAS DONE A
TREMENDOUS SERVICE TO THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS SUPPORTERS
BECAUSE THEY HAVE ALLOWED
THEM NOW TO TREAT THIS AS IF
IT'S A FAIT ACCOMPLI.
IT'S ALL DONE.
WE KNOW WHAT THE BOTTOM LINE
IS.
WHEN IN FACT THERE MAY BE
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
EVIDENCE AND TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF TESTIMONY.
AGAIN WE ARE NOT SURE WE
WILL SEE GRAND JURY
TESTIMONY INDICATING THAT
THERE WAS INVOLVEMENT.
IT JUST DIDN'T RISE TO THE
LEVEL OF INDICTMENT AND
PROSECUTION.
BUT THAT IS, YOU KNOW, A
NUANCES AT THIS POINT.
NONETHELESS, I THINK TODAY
IS GOOD NEWS.
I WOULD SAY THIS TO PEOPLE
ON THE LEFT.
I DON'T THINK THAT YOU
SHOULD GET EXCITED AND
EXPECT THAT, YOU KNOW, YOU
HAVE GOT TO DIAL BACK YOUR
EXPECTATIONS.
I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO
BE DAMNING IN THE FULL
REPORT.
PEOPLE ON THE RIGHT DIAL
BACK THE IDEA YOU THINK AS
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAYS THIS IS
TOTAL VINDICATION BECAUSE I
DON'T THINK THAT'S WHAT IS
COMING.
>> Dana: ARE YOU DIALING UP
OR DIALING DOWN, BACK,
FORWARD?
REVERSE?
>> Kennedy: I'M ON NEUTRAL
ON MOST OF THESE THINGS
BECAUSE I HAVE VERY LOW
EXPECTATIONS OF GOVERNMENT
INDIVIDUALS BY AND LARGE.
I'M NEVER SURPRISED BY THE
PROCESS OR THE ABILITY OF
EITHER SIDE TO POLITICIZE
EACH THE TINIEST PIECE OF
NEWS.
WHAT I WILL SAY ABOUT
WILLIAM BARR, I DON'T SHARE
YOUR UNIVERSAL BLANKET OF
LOVE FOR THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
YOU KNOW, HE IS A FINE PICK.
HE WASN'T ANY FIRST CHOICE.
HE HAS SOME ISSUES IN HIS
PAST.
THIS MUST BE A VERY
DIFFERENT TIME FROM WHICH HE
SERVED UNDER GEORGE H.W.
BUSH.
HE MUST BE OVERWHELMED.
>> Jesse: I WOULD SAY HE IS
BETTER THAN JEFF SESSIONS.
I DON'T KNOW WHY HE WOULD
COMPLETELY UNDERMINE HIS
REPUTATION OF PUTTING OUT A
FALSE SUMMARY OF THE MUELLER
REPORT THAT DOES NOT SERVE
HIM AT ALL IN THE SLIGHTEST.
IS HE NOT GOING TO SEEK THE
PRESIDENCY.
IT DOESN'T SEEM AS THOUGH HE
HAS THESE GRAND POLITICAL
ASPIRATIONS AND, ALSO
SPECIAL COUNSEL IS HELPING
WITH THE REDACTIONS IF THIS
WERE SO COMPLETELY COUNTER
TO WHAT ROBERT MUELLER AND
HIS TEAM HAD BEEN DOING THE
LAST FEW YEARS THEY WOULD
HAVE COME OUT.
THEY ARE DONE.
THEY HAVE WOULD HAVE COME
OUT AND SAID NO, NO, THAT'S
A MISCHARACTERIZATION AND
WORKING ON THE REDACTIONS.
>> Dana: GREG, WE GAVE YOU
TIME TO GET REVVED UP.
>> Greg: WHY WHY NEED TIME?
ARE YOU SUGGESTING THERE IS
SOMETHING GOING GOING ON
WITH ME.
YOU ARE USING THE WORD
DIGEST.
UNFAIR.
I MIGHT HAVE A LITTLE ISSUE
RIGHT NOW THAT IS NOT THE
PUBLIC'S BUSINESS.
AND I WOULD REFRAIN FROM
BRINGING IT UP AGAIN.
LOOK, ALL THIS NEWS IS
BASICALLY TABLE SCRAPS FOR A
BITTER MEDIA WHERE YOU WILL
SEE REDACTIONS.
THEY WILL SCREAM CONSPIRACY.
RACHEL MADDOW WILL BREAK OUT
THE WHITE BOARD BECAUSE THIS
IS THEIR BUSINESS MODEL.
I PREDICT NOT ONLY WILL THEY
FIND COLLUSION AND
OBSTRUCTION.
THEY WILL FIND THE LOCATION
OF BIG FOOT AND THE LOST
CITY OF ATLANTIS, WHICH I
BELIEVE IS SOMEWHERE OUTSIDE
DENVER.
SO THIS IS GOING TO KEEP
GOING.
BECAUSE THE MEDIA WANTS TO
KEEP THIS GOING BECAUSE IT'S
THEIR BUSINESS MODEL AND WHO
BENEFITS FROM THIS?
RUSSIA.
BECAUSE LET'S NOT FORGET THE
PRIMARY GOAL OF RUSSIA WAS
TO UNDERMINE OUR
INSTITUTIONS.
IT WASN'T ABOUT AUTO
ELECTING TRUMP OR ANYBODY.
IT WAS ABOUT SCREWING WITH
OUR MENTALITY.
MAKING US QUESTION
EVERYTHING AND FOMENT CHAOS.
WHO IS FULFILLING THE
RUSSIAN'S GOAL MEDIA AND THE
DEMOCRATS.
EXCEPT JUAN IS CORRECT.
THE ONES THAT DIAL BACK
EXPECTATIONS AND MOVE ON ARE
DOING THE RIGHT THING.
>> Juan: YOU KNOW WHAT I
WOULD SAY AT THIS MOMENT,
BILL BARR IS SO MUCH THE
FOCUS OF ALL OUR ATTENTION.
AND BILL BARR, HAVE YOU GOT
TO REMEMBER AT LEAST FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE, CAMPAIGNED FOR
THIS JOB AND SAID THAT HE
BELIEVED IN EXPENSIVE EXPANSIVE
PRESIDENTIAL POWER.
HE WROTE A LETTER, DANA.
>> Jesse: ARE YOU SUGGESTING
THAT THERE IS A POLITICIAN
INVOLVED IN THIS?
>> Juan: NO, NO, NO.
>> Greg: I'M GOING TO GO
FURTHER.
HAVE YOU EVER SEEN MR. BARR
AND STEVE BANNON TOGETHER AT
THE SAME TIME?
STEVE BANNON WITH GLASSES?
>> Juan: NO, NO, NO.
I THINK HE ATE HIM.
>> Dana: COMPARISON, JESSE,
PERMISSION GRANTED?
>> Jesse: ALLOWED.
>> Dana: I THINK BILL BARR
AS A FORMER ATTORNEY GENERAL
WHO I DON'T THINK
ANTICIPATED GOING BACK.
HE DIDN'T APPLY FOR THE JOB.
WASN'T LEAVE HIS LIFE AS HE
HAD IT TO GO BACK INTO
GOVERNMENT.
>> Jesse: TO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
NOT A LOT OF PEOPLE WANTED
TO DO THAT.
>> Dana: IS HE A LAWYER'S
LAWYER.
I HAVE SOME THOUGHTS ON THIS
JOTS THEM DOWN AND SENDS
THEM OTHER.
IT WOULD BE LIKE LET'S SAY I
DIDN'T HAVE THE JOB I HAVE
NOW BUT I WAS IN P.R.
PRACTICE AND I WAS LIKE, YOU
KNOW, I HAVE SOME ADVICE AND
THOUGHTS FOR SARAH SANDERS.
I'M GOING TO SHOOT HER A
LITTLE LETTER.
DOES THAT SOUND LIKE I'M
CAMPAIGNING TO BE IN A JOB?
>> Kennedy: NO.
YOU HAVE WRITTEN TWO BOOKS
AND ONE OF THEM WAS LARGELY
ABOUT YOUR TIME AS PRESS
SECRETARY FOR THE PRESIDENT.
>> Dana: AND STILL AVAILABLE
ON AMAZON.
>> Greg: ONE ABOUT A DOG
NAMED JASPER IN CASE HAVE
YOU FORGOTTEN.
>> Juan: HE WROTE A LETTER
TO WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL I
THINK THAT TAKES IT TO A
DIFFERENT LEVEL.
>> Dana: MAYBE HE HAVE TO